moving on
our main story tonight concerns nursing
homes the absolute
last thing you want andrew cuomo to be
handling tied comfortably with literally
anything else
nursing homes and long-term care in
general are something that we tend to
try to avoid thinking about but the
truth is
whether due to old age or disability
many of us do or will
require help with daily living the
number of americans 65 and older is
projected to nearly double
over the next 40 years and one study
estimated over two-thirds of americans
who reach 65
will need long-term care at some point
in their lives and the good news is for
the rich
there are plenty of options there are
multiple upscale retirement communities
where residents can transition if needed
into full-time nursing care like this
one
taught in exquisite fashion by two
chains all right so the name of this
episode is called the most expensive
retirement right
and so this is the most upscale
luxurious retirement homes that i've
ever seen and never heard about the
building itself costs 100 million
dollars to build
the the marble it's from uh italy it's a
custom carpet
yeah i see a lot of art i see the
versace plates okay
extravagance off that place aside let's
all just agree that 195 dollar plate
sucks and i'm not normally a plate
guy your boy's a source of freak from
way back i'm a bowl plates aren't
really my thing but even i can tell
that plate is a two that's a two in ohio
if you're gonna spend that kind of money
on a plate it better be really big
really fun or really really hot
that plate look at me put your phone
down and look at me when i'm talking to
you
that plate
but the fact is most of us aren't ending
up in that place in fact
the vast majority of people receive
long-term care at home and around 80
percent of that care
is provided by unpaid caregivers often
family members who want to keep their
loved ones
out of institutional care like this wife
and daughter
cheryl and kristen are among the 42
million americans
caring for loved ones at home and the
tasks they perform have become
increasingly complex when we have to
flush his picc line or clean his peg
tube or
take his blood glucose or his blood
pressure you know
none of us went to school for that i
mean we're not educated that way
i don't feel like i had enough training
at all for this we've kind of learned by
trial and error
that seems really hard and there are
certain things you kind of expect to do
by trial and error solving a puzzle
learning to pronounce the name of
tambourine saturday or choosing a
haircut and for the record
error error error and
error but providing essential medical
care should not be one of those things
taking care of someone at home can be an
incredibly complicated full-time job
that is
almost always unpaid in fact in terms of
lost wages
the labor of family caregivers totals
about 67
billion dollars annually that's a
workforce that if it were paid
would rival the entire gdp of bulgaria
but for those who cannot afford to eat
off unfuckable plates or whose loved
ones
are unable to help them at home many
wind up in long-term care facilities
there are
two million people in them in the united
states
and as we've seen during the covid
crisis they can be far from ideal
residents and staff in them make up less
than one percent of the population but
currently account
for around a third of covid deaths the
pandemic
pushed an already heavily strained
system to the absolute brink
with conditions getting so bad that were
near constant local news stories like
this one
one resident here says her calls for
help were ignored because there wasn't
enough staff to respond
i was screaming get me out of here get
me out of here this thing i was
screaming at them i was in terrible pain
and they didn't come for me
penny shaw was in pain as she lay
helpless in her bed at braintree manor
nursing home
in the midst of the covet 19 pandemic
she became
so desperate she even called braintree
police for help
i can't lay in bed for hours and hours
you know in pain like that
now i have to tell you we contacted that
facility which
chose not to address its staffing levels
back then in its response to us instead
insisting that
the safety of its residents is of utmost
importance
but that is pretty hard to
believe when they're calling the police
for help
there are only two instances where lying
in bed for hours screaming in pain is to
be expected and that's if you're giving
birth
or you're digesting a crunchwrap supreme
that
is it and the truth is covert just
exposed what we've basically known for
years that the way the elderly and
disabled are treated in
far too many of these facilities is with
at best indifference
and at worst abuse and neglect so
tonight
let's talk about long-term care how the
industry is structured how that
structure creates
bad incentives and what we can do going
forward and we're going to focus
on the two main types of long-term care
facilities nursing homes
and assisted living nursing homes are
medical facilities
overseen by registered nurses and
largely staffed by low-paid nursing
assistants
and there have long been issues with
nursing home care a gao report covering
a five-year period
before the pandemic found that 82 of
homes had been cited for infection
prevention and control deficiencies and
about half
had persistent problems that have been
cited across multiple years
and a big reason for that may be because
understaffing
is a huge problem with employees often
tasked with taking care of
way too many residents as these nursing
assistants pointed out just last year
they're not being showered people
falling out of bed the men aren't being
shaved
people fall into where they fell out of
their wheelchairs what if they need
change
they might get it one time a day a day
we have
22 residents a piece most days
that's for one person to
wash dress get up two meals
and they're being neglected because you
can't get to everybody i told the
administrator
i'm embarrassed of my work my work
process it
because i can't do
what i was trained to do on how to take
care of these residents
that is obviously unacceptable do you
have any idea how bad things need to get
for you to tell your boss you're
embarrassed by your work
i'm not even embarrassed by my work and
just three minutes ago i joked about
a plate
also that wasn't really a joke call me
wolf plate
and nursing assistants aren't just
overworked they are really
underpaid the median national salary for
that job is barely 30
000 a year and one reason is that nearly
70 percent of nursing homes are now
for-profit institutions and there is
a lot of profit for them to make because
they don't pay staff much
but they charge you a lot the average
per person cost for a private room
is a hundred thousand dollars per year
and if you're thinking well yeah that is
expensive but
doesn't the medicare program that i've
paid into all my life cover that
well no it doesn't medicare only fully
covers
the first 20 days of nursing home care
after an eligible hospital visit
then partially pays for up to 100 days
but after that
you are on the hook for all costs
the only other way to access taxpayer
help to live in a nursing home is to
almost
completely impoverish yourself to
basically spend your way down to the
point you qualify for medicaid
the government program for the poor
which crucially reimburses nursing homes
at less than half the average daily rate
paid by medicare
and while you would like to think that
nursing homes would treat all patients
the same whether they're on medicare
or medicaid the truth is you might get
two
very different experiences because if
you're on medicare
you could wind up getting too much
attention just listen to an assistant
manager at one nursing home chain
describe how medicare patients there
were treated what percentage of the
therapy that
you were being told to administer do you
think was not necessary
i would say probably as time went on
about
forty percent forty percent of the work
that you were doing
was not reasonable and not necessary
under medicare guidelines
at another facility the entire rehab
staff signed a letter to their boss
it reads we've been encouraged to
maximize reimbursement even when
clinically
inappropriate that is absurd the doj
actually filed a lawsuit claiming that
the chain that that woman worked for
life care centers of america which runs
over 200 nursing homes was subjecting
his patients to therapy even as they
were on their death beds
it alleged one 92 year old who was dying
of metastatic cancer
was recorded as having had 48 minutes of
physical therapy
47 minutes of occupational therapy and
30 minutes of speech therapy
just two days before his death on a day
he was spitting up blood
which is ridiculous residents should be
getting proper
nursing care not tons of expensive
therapeutic treatments that are
clinically inappropriate which by the
way
i'm pretty sure was the original slogan
of goop
now life care denied wrongdoing but
agreed to pay
145 million dollars to resolve that
lawsuit and they're hardly alone here
over the past decade multiple other
large nursing home chains
have been charged with fraudulent
medicare billing practices and denied
wrongdoing while paying tens of millions
of dollars to settle their cases you
know
like you do when you are totally
innocent so to recap here
if medicare is paying the risk is that
you could be billed for unnecessary
treatments but if medicaid
is paying which remember reimburses
nursing homes at less than half the
average daily rate
things could get much worse because if
facilities want to open up a bed to a
more
lucrative patient they can take drastic
action
ronald who was 51 and homeless got rehab
at the nursing home where he lived for
more than a year
then one night around 10 pm he says an
administrator came into his room
big smile on their face saying they're
kicking you out
they smiled yeah and they just bundled
me into a
a van and just dropped me off here on
the sidewalk the avalon villa care
center
through its lawyers told nbc news it
strongly disputes that it has
inappropriately discharged
any patients the homeless shelter where
ronald's living now
says it's seen cases like this before
experts even have a term for it
resident dumping oh come on that is just
evil resident dumping is a
completely unacceptable practice
i don't even like it when residents are
dumped on grey's anatomy
at the alter berk you dump that resident
at the
altar how could you do that to
christina you monster
and you would hope regulators would
punish nursing homes for doing things
like that but the oversight here
has some massive gaps for instance the
federal government keeps a list of
so-called
special focus facilities homes that have
a pattern of serious problems
over a long period of time and therefore
receive extra
inspections there are 88 nursing homes
on that list but interestingly
not because there are only 88 homes that
deserve to be it's because
due to limited resources the government
has capped the list at that exact number
despite the fact
they fully acknowledge an additional 400
facilities
qualify for the program and look i'm not
saying every list
should go on forever if a list of cutest
otters was capped at 88
that'd be a perfectly fine list but if
there were 400
other cute otters that were also abusing
the elderly
i'd really like to know who all of them
are and if you're thinking well look
that is good to know that's good
information if i need to move a loved
one into a nursing home i'm definitely
going to look online and make sure it's
a good one
well be careful because while the
government does have a website where
nursing homes are rated from one to five
stars it has an absolutely
massive loophole of the three factors
that determine an overall rating
only the health inspections are
conducted independently
the other statistics staffing and
quality measures
are self-reported by the nursing home
these self-reported statistics can boost
a three-star rating
into a five-star rating overall the
problem is
you know it's garbage in garbage out so
whatever they're telling the feds the
feds are not the federal government
isn't going
in and double checking that their
numbers are accurate yeah
garbage in garbage out and that is
pathetic
something as important as our nursing
home rating system should not follow the
same rule as every recipe on velveeta's
website
because there is just no way any of
those are any good
if you're making a recipe the cause for
a puddle of lorax jizz
then don't be surprised when the
finished product is equally repulsive
it's garbage in
garbage out so given everything that
you've seen so far it's hardly
surprising that
for reasons of cost or conditions many
might want to avoid a nursing home
altogether which brings us to assisted
living facilities or
alfs around a third of people in
long-term care facilities
are in one of these and they do cost far
less than a nursing home typically
around 50 000 a year alf started out as
an alternative for those who
needed help with key activities like
dressing toileting taking medicines and
eating but
only needed limited medical support just
as with nursing homes the vast majority
of alfs are
for profit but there are also some key
differences
alfs are largely paid for out of pocket
and
they are far less regulated making it
easy for basically
anyone to start one and i do mean anyone
take stephanie costa by the age of 30
she owned
six small alfs in southern california
and made a lot of money from them
enough to qualify her to appear in an
episode of the millionaire matchmaker
my name is stephanie and i'm 30 years
old and i own
a chain of elderly care facilities
my nep worth is three to four million
probably
i've always had this thing of taking
care of older people like
sick people that are dying i've always
really felt for them
so i couldn't wait to graduate college
and start my own business
doing assisted living facilities like
nursing homes
okay uh there are a lot of unfair
reasons that i inherently don't trust
stephanie costa from her
driving a douchey ferrari to the fact
that she looks like an uncredited extra
from an entourage party scene
to that voice which sounds like a mouse
who wouldn't dress cinderella because it
had better things to do
but it turns out that gut feeling is
actually entirely valid because costa
treated her employees and residents so
terribly that after multiple health and
safety violations
california banned her from the industry
for life and
ordered her and her company to pay about
1.6 million
for unpaid wages and penalties but if
you think that that gave her
accountability
you're gonna want to think again she
kept this home after filing for
bankruptcy and settled with workers for
a fraction of what she owed
her six care homes are now owned by a
property investment company registered
by her father
oh yeah not just that as recently as
last year she was still
listed as that company's ceo so the
state of california
really taught stephanie costa a lesson
there specifically the lesson that you
can
treat your elder care workers like
absolute avoid any real
consequences
and just keep living your life in the
single ugliest home in beverly hills
although it's legitimately hard to tell
whether that is actually a home
or just an abandoned white castle but
it's not just
individuals involved here there are also
big corporations running alfs who've
been working hard
to fill up beds and despite the fact
that als remember
are supposed to be for people who
require less medical attention recently
some have been aggressively caught in
dementia patients for memory care
programs
as seen in this advertisement for
brookdale the largest alf provider in
the country
this is a compassionate place that helps
families through
very difficult stages of dementia in a
safe and comfortable setting
and i have peace of mind knowing their
staff fully trained 24 hours a day
seven days a week i can't believe how
much my mom's quality of life has
improved since coming here
i'm seeing her smiling and laughing
again we help them maintain their
abilities and encourage the use of their
current skills in a warm
engaging environment this is a special
place
and every day is a new beginning with
lots of smiles and memories
okay i get that a senior living
commercial might want to have at least
one staff or with their arms around a
resident's shoulders it's kind of nice
trustworthy makes you feel safe but
immediately cutting to another one feels
like a bit much and then a third
starts to make me feel a little nervous
and when that fourth one hits as a
british person i've got to say
that is just too much physical contact
that said
even i will admit an alf that offered
all that commercial claims to
but with significantly less touching
would really be great unfortunately
a woman who worked at a brookdale
facility of south carolina painted a
pretty worrying picture
of how staffers are trained to work with
dementia patients when you first start
they have you set through a series of
in-services or orientation it lasts
about a week
but it's just videos but once they put
you out on the floor they don't
they don't give you any training they
just stick you out there
well that's not really ideal is it
because it's hard to retain
important information just by watching a
video case in point
this video think about it what have you
really learned from this sure a few
random facts about the long-term care
industry that you'll probably
immediately forget but if you're
honest you've mainly learned that it's
possible to want to a plate
and that's a lesson you will never
forget and look
brookdale insists that it offers ongoing
training for its workers and that its
training program for dementia care
workers
meets or exceeds state guidelines but
that is not really
saying much as some states require only
two to
thirty hours of specialized training and
south carolina
where that facility is located requires
training but
doesn't set a minimum number of hours
and by the way
if you're wondering about why there were
a bunch of shots of a pond in that story
the answer
is completely horrifying because a 90
year old resident there who was supposed
to be under constant supervision
before being transferred to a memory
care unit died after leaving the
facility unnoticed in the middle of the
night
there are signs that are warning people
about alligators take a look at this one
it says alligators may live here be
gator safe in this case the signs
probably would not have made a
difference according to authorities
we are told the victim likely slipped or
fell down a steep embankment
and landed in the water attracting the
gator's attention
holy i honestly don't even
know where to begin there but i guess
i'd start with
why would anyone put an assisted living
facility next to a
alligator pond that seems like
the sort of detail
that really has to be included at the
end of one of brookdale's heartwarming
ads
this is a special place and every day is
a new beginning with lots of smiles and
memories
also one of our residents was eaten by
an alligator
so you know there's that yeah
there is that and that's important
information for people to know brookdale
and look obviously that is an appalling
story but to be fair
it's hard to talk about long-term care
without showing you at least one of
those
just be grateful i didn't show you the
story where a resident jumped from a
fourth story window of an alf
or the one about a nursing home resident
who set herself on fire or the one about
a 91 year old suffering from alzheimer's
who froze to death on christmas day
which by the way
sounds like a holiday album written by
bjork
so what can we do here well obviously
increased oversight and enforcement are
badly needed
that facility with the alligators was
eventually fined by the state for 11
violations including
not properly performing night checks and
letting staffing
drop below required levels but the
penalty issued was just 6 400
and it feels like if you lost a loved
one in such a horrific way
you would want more accountability than
just don't worry someone decided their
life was worth the price of a 2013
chrysler motown
and the fact is there are lots of ideas
on how to force facilities to improve
mandating a certain level of money has
to go to patient care for instance or
that
residents have access to a minimum
amount of care per day
but the bigger fix here might be to try
and make it easier
for as many people as possible not to
end up in these institutions in the
first place and instead receive whatever
support they need at home
nearly 90 percent of people over 65
apparently want to stay
in their home for as long as possible
which does
make sense the problem is right now
many of them can't because under
medicaid
nursing home care is an entitlement but
home-based care
is not to access long-term services and
supports through medicaid in your home
you need a waiver from your state and to
be fair some like washington
do that pretty well more than 70 percent
of the medicaid money they spend on
long-term care for older people
and adults with disabilities is spent on
home and community-based services that's
things like
skilled nursing visits home care aides
who can help with daily tasks
and even the ability to pay family
caregivers you know
people like those two women that you saw
earlier the problem is
other states have waiting lists that can
be many years long
by which point seniors trying to access
that care
can be dead because sadly that is how
time works
nationwide more than 800 000 people are
on these kinds of waiting lists
what we need is reform at a national
level and there are actually some
promising developments here
a discussion draft of a bill was
recently introduced that would make
home and community-based care an
entitlement under medicaid
and biden's proposed infrastructure plan
actually calls for 400 billion dollars
to be spent on those exact services and
that would be
a really big deal and look any
aggressive transition
to home-based care is going to need
rigorous guardrails and oversight
to make sure that money is not misspent
just in a different way
the last thing i want is five years from
now to be having to do a show on the
evils of new for-profit home care
agencies
who've somehow been destroying people's
lives in their own homes and if you're
thinking wait hold on
five years from now you'll still be
doing shows in the void oh no
we'll be back in the void i don't want
to get into specifics but spoiler alert
it's not a pandemic next time it's
spiders but we do need to do something
and it all starts with showing that we
give a about what happens to the
elderly and people with disabilities in
this country because right now
evidence points to the fact that we
absolutely don't and
all the other problems are stemming from
that
and the longer that we continue to
ignore this the worse it's going to get
because the fact is
right now this is an industry where the
people in its care are being
figuratively
and sometimes literally eaten alive
you